if you don't need to wash your hair
twice why does a foam more on the second
wash hi I have a PhD in super molecular
chemistry so this sort of thing is kind
of my area the surfactants are
responsible for making foam but they're
also responsible for suspending the oil
into the water basically if you have
surfactants suspending the oil into the
water in Emulsion droplets that means
they're not available to make foam so if
you have more oil you will have less
foam but even if one wash has gotten all
of the oil off your hair the second wash
is still going to more all it means is
there's more oil in the first wash and
less in the second wash less could mean
zero oil now if you wash a third time
and you see more foam then that means
your second wash was doing something so
it's like the amount of foam in each
wash is telling you something about the
previous wash not about that wash so n
minus one